this is a production of cornell
university
so yes i'm going to talk about
one of our most
favorite plant types today and as i go
through this
what i'm going to try and get you to do
is to think and and i i'm going to
put some things on here that basically
might change your thinking might
solidify your thinking
but i want you to to think more broadly
about weeds because
i think a lot of this has to do with
some of our preconceived ideas and and
maybe some of the things that we've
learned over time
but i will just get into this
and um
this might be familiar to some of you uh
not sure but um
you know this guy out here he's he's not
real old uh he's he's laying down on the
job
but you can see he's quite frustrated
and uh you know asking him about this
new frontier are you kidding me this is
no new frontier this is the same old
thing i've been doing
uh you know for the past few years of my
life
so
our attitude towards weeds
now i've i've put this into i'm just
giving broad terms to conventional
thinking and sustainable thinking now
these are not good or bad this is just
how we sometimes tend to think
so in conventional type systems
you know typically you want 100 percent
weed free
we know that they negatively compete
with
available resources so eliminating weeds
is is number one priority
and there's obviously there's a
relationship with economic losses
associated with those systems
in more sustainable systems or
sustainable thinking
you know often it's it's density
thresholds how many weeds are out there
can i can i get by with and are they
really having an impact that i need to
work with
also plant diversity so that thinking
more broadly you know there's these are
plants they're adding diversity to the
system
and also are they providing an
alternative cover whether it's a mulch
whether it's you know something else
that allows these um
allows them to
remain in these systems
but the impacts of weeds
and through the literature uh various
studies
good or bad okay and this is somewhat
conflicting and again it's based on kind
of your thinking
and and
and what you're kind of geared toward
but we can think of weeds as either they
compete
for resources or they contribute to
resources through you know biomass
or
competing for available resources they
inhibit or assist operations whether
that's harvest you know
clogging up your harvester or you know
providing a mulch
harbor insects and diseases or support
beneficials
increase
agronomic
biodiversity but maybe lower
diversity in our natural systems where
you see invasive plants becoming
monocultures
there's kind of you know
this diver biodiversity issue and then
also increased production costs
uh or are we increasing the
environmental benefits if you think of a
weed as a plant that has some
desirable characteristics so this is a
bit of a conflict
and i don't think it's been resolved
completely
but if we look back so historically
we're looking back because we want to
know what have we gone through what have
we worked on
so wheat is defined as a plant out of
place i think most of you have heard
that definition
but ralph waldo emerson is as defined as
a plant whose virtues have not yet been
discovered
so instead of looking at the glass as
half empty he's looking at it as half
full
so
over time now i've put this
this time scale
back
in the early days all the way up to here
and you can see that and this is
basically relating to weeds
you know whether we had the first hand
implements
then we get into horse-drawn
mechanical
the chemical era begins with the first
herbicide or the
24d herbicide
some you know internet was invented in
1973 okay why is that important to weeds
well i'll get into that as far as
technology
we have the first herbicide resistant
rye grass
resistant to to um
seven sites of actions
so if you're familiar with the herbicide
resistance scenario
or or issue there's there's different
sites of actions with the different
modes of actions and this rye grass here
is is is pretty major
and this occurred in 1982
if we look at certified organic systems
was certified in the us in 1990
the executive order and everyone's
familiar with
the clinton era when they
declared invasive species as something
that we need to start managing
or they made it an executive order
and now we have climate hubs developed
in 2013
and uh the most recent research that
i've seen is the development of an
automated weeder by some folks at uc
davis
so these are kind of some of the events
that contribute to what i'm going to
talk about
but in addition to those changes we've
also had you know ecological the theory
has advanced over that same time period
and we've also seen some practical
application in our management so that's
changed whether we're talking about hand
implements all the way up to an
automated weeder okay so
we're seeing a lot of changes over time
that i think also contribute to our our
viewpoint and our
thinking
but weeds and ecosystems
they're either resilient
or they're pesky
and
this is based on kind of perception but
in in these natural ecosystems
semi-natural or urban ecosystems
weeds tend to be survivors they tend to
persist
they're very prolific in in either
producing seed or producing biomass and
in some ways you could view them as
opportunistic
they look for niches and i i'm giving
them kind of human qualities but
niches are what they take advantage of
and and that's really what we see
especially when you look at a lot of
these
in our managed system there's a lot of
disturbance going on there so there's
opportunities that are created for weeds
so i'm going to talk about kind of three
main areas and this is related to the
things that i
have done research on or what my
interests were
prior to coming here
and i'm going to just talk about these
three things just to get us thinking
about
more broadly as far as weeds and
invasive plants
so super weeds now
super weeds is a very um
it kind of gets your attention whether
it's at the emotional level or or
whatever you've probably seen it in the
popular press
associated with
genetically modified crops
so this article by
by kogan in 2005 talked about super
weeds are impossible to kill
well they're impossible to kill if
you're using one herbicide and
if it's glyphosate you're going to have
a glyphosate resistant
gene that's either transferred
to
the weed
or the indiscriminate spraying of
glyphosate onto resistant gm crops
you're basically providing selection
pressure to
allow for a resistant weedy plant
okay so
herbicide resistant are they really
super weeds well we've you probably i
don't maybe you've seen this graph but
this is from ian heap and his weed
science
website
basically we've seen a dramatic increase
in herbicide resistant weeds
and for those of you who don't know
palmer amaranth in the south
in cotton fields has been a huge uh
issue for them
to deal with
and it's actually forced some growers to
even go out of
growing cotton
but it's a nice you know poster child
herbs herbicide resistant weeds
again these characteristics
contribute to its success
in these cropping systems
so i'm going to take you through a
a time lapse if you will
in 1989 the first palmer amaranth
resistance was identified in
tennessee and
georgia if my geography is correct so
south carolina thank you
we'll get to georgia
so 1990
91
93 94 95 97
98 2000
and i'm just going to go right ahead and
just you can see that continually we're
seeing these plants 2012
and again this is uh from the herbicide
resistance website but you can see that
in each of these states at least one
individual or one population has been
identified resistance to herbicide
so
is what is what's going to happen you
know onwards is there going to be just
uniform resistance
um we hope not
but i'm going to shift gears so there's
the resistance issue but also
in my work i was especially interested
in extreme events and what we're seeing
in especially in the midwest
was significant drought and significant
impacts of drought on cropping systems
and so there's been a lot of work there
still is a lot of work on developing
drought tolerant crops
corn soybeans things like that
but for as much for what i know there's
not a real interest or there's not a lot
of work in drought tolerant weeds or
invasive plants now i know
tony has
written some things and there's some
folks that are working on it but as far
as the real focused effort
it's not
it's not a lot of work has been done on
that but
just to kind of define it's a delay in
lethal dehydration
usually it's related to the physiology
or morpho morphology of the plant
and we see a phenotypic plasticity where
the plant eater uses less water
it loses less water
or it gains access to water through root
penetration through the ground
and then there's also the genetic
adaptation where
over time
if there's it's another selection
pressure
that
is is creating
a change in the population
and this depends a lot on the intensity
and duration of that selection pressure
so as i indicated
in 2012
we saw this chart
from the u.s drought monitor
and this central part of the country was
either red or brown for most of the year
and so i looked at phragmites australis
which i think you folks have some of
that out here uh either
good or bad
but looking at phragmites common reed
and its tolerance to drought so we
looked we had a greenhouse study we set
up
basically we had these large tanks
where we um
transplanted phragmites
and then we submitted or
exposed them to different stress periods
and this we had a low stress medium
stress and severe stress
and basically that was
related to
the number of days that there was no
water in those
mesocosms
and so for our low stress we had 19 days
of no water
which
in addition there were four days where
it was at greater than 80 percent
available water was depleted
so
we're getting down to very very dry
conditions essentially
and so our medium stress was 36 days
with no water 20 days at at greater than
80 percent and then our severe
stress basically a month of of no water
and out of those out of that 60 days
there were about 44 days where it was
significantly dry
so what did we see
in our low stress treatment
where we had seven this is day 70. so on
on day 70 we added water back into those
tanks
and you know
looking at this
you'd say well that plant is either dead
or it has gone dormant
well it was actually dormant because 25
days post drought
it had started to green up now this is
just the low stress
i was convinced that the severe stress
we'd killed those plants i thought
they're dead
absolutely well
not the case because
25 days later
those plants were starting to green up
and you can ask well did you get all the
water out of that soil we had soil
moisture sensors that were basically
reading zero and i know there's you know
there's probably could have been pockets
of water in those systems but
very much an indication that this plant
is is very tolerant to
drought conditions
and maybe some of you are familiar with
that or have worked on this particular
species
um shifting gears a little bit
cardus nutans which is mustacel
we looked at an invasion study
into cool and warm season perennial
grasses and we had simulated grazing for
two years
we also introduced mustacil
in the first year in the spring of the
first year
and part of this study was very
interesting in that we had normal
precipitation one year and then we went
into our drought year in 2012 which was
um the the worst drought that they've
had on record so it was really nice for
our study it was horrible for people
that were you know cropping and and that
part
uh but it worked out really well for us
to to compare that
so i'm just going to go right to the
results um
and then again along the uh
the x-axis here is the the the dates so
april 2011
all the way up to november 2012
and then here's our volumetric water
content
these represent the the various
treatments whether it was bare ground
must the soil by itself
warm season grazed warm season
non-grazed cool season grades cool
season hungary's but basically this
shows you that
in the second year
where we had our
must and i realize these lines are not
really easy for you to see but where
there was not basically non-grazing so
our non-grazed treatments
we had there was water content but where
we had our must thistle and then
anything where there was grazing if i'm
reading that right i had depleted water
down so we saw a difference in water
content between these two treatments
and this is a really great graph
especially if you're
tired and you want to
go to sleep really easily
and pardon me for the the the busyness
but along here the x these are all our
treatments
and this is basically looking at light
penetration into the canopy over may
june july and august of 2011 and then
the same thing in 2012. so so what i
want to highlight
is at the initial part of our study
we had
good plant cover
so if you think so if you see a high bar
that means um
there's a lot of light
penetrating into this to the soil
surface if you see a bars that are low
that means there's not a lot of light
reaching the soil surface
so looking at and i'm just going to
point out a couple these two treatments
our warm season non-grazed must thistle
where we added it and warm season um
uh where we just added uh mustard by
itself
or sorry warm season non-graze without
muscle so you can see in 2011
it's doing a good job at shading out the
soil surface
but in 2012 and these are perennial
grasses they should be growing robustly
you know providing some good shade in
2012
the drought was affecting
these grasses where they had now were
allowing
light to penetrate the soil surface
and you say well why is that important
well for muscus so it's very important
and once it gets access to light
with enough soil moisture
it grows very well
again here's the same thing this is just
looking at populations over time so in
2011 2012 i'm just highlighting this our
warm season non-grazed where we
introduced muslim so you can see here
early on it started to establish
but then in august
it disappeared
same thing in 2012 it started to
establish
by july those plants were dead
so what was going on
in 2011 we had great soil moisture we
had normal precipitation
we had very nice establishment of muscle
in our grazed treatments
in our non-grazed plots in 2012
this is basically muscular emerging and
then it would die without producing a
flower or any kind of a seed head
and just for comparison here's our
beautiful bare ground plots of must
thistle which
we did get a lot of attention by people
driving but this is right by a highway
and they would drive by and say you need
to control that it was you know because
the noxious weed and we were trying to
do research on it
we we were we were
we bagged all the seed heads so just to
let you know we didn't let all the seed
just go everywhere we were we were
bagging the seed heads and then the
second year we chopped all this down and
i i did actually get a chance to operate
a shovel and uh take care of any uh
remaining so
but this is just to
just a little bit of an uh kind of an
introduction of
where we're seeing this
tolerance or not tolerating these dry
drought
conditions
so
does tolerant or resistance make it
super
well
we also know that there's
there's
weeds that are tolerant to mowing
they're tolerant to disking or
disturbances it's really dependent on
intensity and duration
and it's not super but they're actually
resilient
so phenologically or genetically it
adapts to environmental stress
whether you know an example is drought
uh it these plants are able to evolve um
as far as their defense mechanisms
uh you know and this is an example of
herbicides
and they're also able to access spatial
temporal resources whether that's light
water nutrients now i
i'm saying this related to weeds
but again they're just plants
they're not
you know some for formidable
foe that is that is that we can't really
deal with and i'll talk about that at
the end as well
so bioenergy
i'm going to shift gears here a little
bit bioenergy research
this is just a map of of where
some of the regional
projects have been conducted across the
country and this is a little bit dated
it's not really up to date
but just to show you and i think
everyone is aware of the bioenergy
research that's going on
there's several resources there's
several
things that folks are looking at
obviously corn corn residue
switch grass perennial grasses
has been some interest in miscanthus
gigantis
biodiesel soybeans canola camilla
camelina and others
i just want to point out there's
even within this group there's folks
looking at
grass bioenergy
but there's also been some interest in
uh invasive plants as uh bioenergy
sources
and if you look at these three photos
the thing or sorry for my math is not
working well um you can see that
there's high amounts of biomass right
that's that's the big interest is how
can we create a lot of biomass
to you know create ethanol and provide
some fuel well
like we discussed for palmer
invasive plants have some similar
characteristics they're fast growing
high biomass relatively few pests
they create these dense monocultures and
there's few inputs to kind of keep them
going
but on the flip side of that
they that is a great scenario for
invasion
and there's there's a lot of potential
with these plants some have already you
know some already are already doing
their invasive work
the weed risk assessments is it anyone
familiar with weed risk assessment so
assessing a plant for its um
it's
invasive or its
ability to become a problem
most of these assessments on these
plants are positive they're it's they're
highly
problematic or they could be highly
problematic
peer-reviewed position papers
these are just two of many papers that
have opposed
this kind of a
you know use of these invasive plants
as well as public land managers
i mean when you say hey guess what we're
going to use these for bioenergy they
say are you crazy
because it's it's a it's a thing that
we're always managing
and then somehow you want to protect
that to create a
fuel source
well
a new approach i think is is important
here and this gets back to what how do
we think about this
and if we're harvesting existing
populations
and the focus is on control and
restoration
i think it's a little bit different
scenario
and also if we can
co-mingle these
sources with other resources
you address the sustainability issue
so there's a paper in uh frontiers in uh
in 2013
they basically looked at bioenergy that
sports ecological restoration and they
were focused on these two uh
invasive plants russian olive and
tamarisk in washington state
they had a 52-acre restoration site
and this is this was all a
model they did this by modeling so there
wasn't actual you know it wasn't an
actual field study but they looked at
you know all the the available tamers
russian olive
kind of assessed the biomass and found
out that um
you know there's there was a significant
amount that could be produced per year
and they estimated for decades so they
compared their data to national
estimates
and basically what they came up with was
that they said we could ex they could
expand restoration activities and
biomass supplies
which would then uh
create revenue um
well so it would be supported by
revenues from the sale of the invasive
uh tree woodway so basically you're
supporting that that that restoration
effort by the sale of the invasive plant
biomass so you're trying to create this
system that supports itself
so
i'd seen that i'd already been thinking
about this and i i've submitted numerous
proposals with other colleagues
different disciplines uh you know just
an example of some of the proposals we
submitted
we've submitted to numerous funding
sources requesting up to 15 million
dollars with zero
funded
so
if anyone is interested in this if you
want to pursue this
i'd be happy to talk to you about it
but just realize what you're up against
and um
then and and i'm going to show you
some of the barriers of why okay so it's
an ideological you know how are we
thinking about this
there's environmental risk we already
know that there's a weed risk and even
if you're transporting this stuff
there's potential that okay you could
distribute it you know in the in the
pathway somewhere
economical i've run into this over and
over you know these plants are not
sustainable if we harvested everything
there wouldn't be enough to supply the
energy needs that we're looking at you
know so it's not a particularly energy
dense material
there's social issues
conflicting of national agendas so the
department of energy says hey grow this
stuff
yet the usda says no we need to control
it
so um
you know you can't it's hard to go to
them and propose something when there's
not really agreement between agencies
so we're we're going through all this
we're having this really good discussion
meanwhile the invasive plants continue
to spread
because they don't really care what we
think
okay so but this is just uh some ideas
that that i've been thinking about and
working on uh in when i was my previous
previous location so
the last thing i want to talk about is
automation
and just to to preface that so in
agriculture
i looked at you know some of the trends
that are occurring
and we've looked we've seen that uh land
use in ag has dropped from 54 to 51
percent so that's you know kind of
holding steady
labor declined 30 percent um
while agricultural predict productivity
increased 50 percent
larger farms 97 family owned um
i i guess i'm not going to question i
mean this is a report by the usda
but the thing i want to really point out
here is the increased adoption of new
technologies
and that's really what we're seeing in
some of our cropping systems
but in addition to that we're kind of
we've got these challenges that we're
trying to address whether they're
limited resources water nutrients energy
we have conditions that are that are
continually we're dealing with whether
they're pests diseases
disasters and now we're seeing you know
climate change extreme events
but there's also challenges to
innovation
the application logistics as well as the
one we always like to work on is funding
but
what is the available what is the
technology that's out there what are you
know what is kind of the new thing that
that is on the horizon or actually being
um developed
well in our our human health system our
human health area
they now have cameras that can you can
actually swallow
and they can look inside you different
you know find different things that are
right or wrong i don't know if that's
good or bad
uh you can uh you you could they could
unlock your car from space now
uh
we've all gone through this one where
you're going through the airport and and
they can see everything
um and then this one with the you know
they can determine if you've washed your
hands uh because there's sensors that
that show
uh what is what's actually been done uh
so that you know could be beneficial if
you have a
two or three year old and you tell them
what to do and they don't always do it
um
and then here is the one for all you
gamers out there that just you know uh
like to
get in these now these games are getting
real interactive and you can actually
play you know across geographic
locations and
but this is the kind of technology that
probably is nothing new to a lot of you
and there's even other things going on
but i just thought
um this
this a new biology for the 21st century
they point out that
you know computational sciences and
engineers are part of this biological
research that's going on this this
emerging trend
and this is a quote from bill gates back
in 2008 on the special edition on
robotics
and basically says when or even if this
industry robotics will achieve critical
mass
if it does it may well change the world
well we're six years later and i think
we're seeing some of those changes
even within our cropping systems
here's john reed
director of production technology at
john deere
and they're saying that
opportunities to follow a different path
to higher productivity
one that involves automation control and
robotics so you've seen their 48 row
planter
but they're also looking at
very small individual
robots that move in the field and and
that's an area that these companies are
looking at as well
so what is the idea with this automation
stuff well if we've got weeds in our
cropping system
we want to produce this we want to
support these people but we also want to
maintain our natural resources our
economics
but we don't necessarily want to revert
to that
so
how do we do all this and can we
you know use automation to
help in this process
if we talk about integrated weed
management
uh
a lot of treatment factors that that
contribute to the decisions that need to
be made
and i'm not going to go into detail on
these but selection method application
amount
timing plant conditions environmental
conditions these
are some of the factors that are
considered in integrated weed management
and then you think about well if we're
talking automation
we've got machine factors that include
logistics
uh if we're working in real time
uh and then also guidance if you're
talking about something that's that's
autonomous
so targeted recognition and application
systems actually are possible
and i'm going to show you some examples
of research if you look at the the
literature on on engineering
they're really working in this
weed science area more than maybe some
of the weed scientists so they're kind
of doing this work and i think there's a
real opportunity for
overlap or collaboration
between these two fields
so if we talk about the spatial temporal
identification and management of weeds
basically predicting uh where the weeds
are based on environmental factors
we're really good at predicting not
always
versus treatable based on location and
plant characteristics
so i'm going to focus on this one uh
just in the uh in the in the next few
minutes
so based on location
so locating the weeds and there's some
uh i think
there's been work done you know where
are weeds in the field how do we find
those do you do you go through and uh
you know
do it by hand you you do it with uh
sensors or or
computers
but you can create these maps
and this is a comparison of maps created
either
by
manual weed mapping so going out and
mapping those by hand
semi
automated weed mapping kind of a hybrid
between hand weeding or hand
by hand versus
using technology and then on automated
weed mapping
and you can see that um
they're
they're pretty close there there's some
relationship there
and what they found was the weed density
uh in in most cases the difference was
due to leaf occlusion so
when you've got overlapping weeds
it's it's hard for
the technology to identify
well this is a weed and this is separate
it just looks at it as one weed so
that's part of the the issue with why
there's not a real nice
relationship between those two
but if we we talk about loca so we know
okay we look in the field where are they
what about plant characteristics can we
look at some of the characteristics of
the plant to help us identify
some of this and this early work was
back in the 1980s
looking at
sunflowers and soybeans and basically
looking at near-infrared photography
but we've obviously we've advanced from
that from that point on in the early
1990s they've developed these commercial
spot sprayers
basically looking at if there's green
foliage or brown soil
so when the green comes up that's you
know an indication to spray
but we're we're getting beyond that now
we're getting to where we've got some
a knowledge based
machine vision system
and it's kind of based on on these
principles you could you know view this
as a decision support
tool but
visually you know
finding where the plants are
and then through a series of steps
identifying those plants
and then even going to the species
classification and population
and then we can develop a weed map
that's very specific and and allows us
to have a strategic approach
this right here
is the hard part
you can find the plants
but
getting to individual leaflets looking
at leaf shape venation texture analysis
species classification
this is uh the the problem with this
particular
approach so
here's an example this is
from the norwegian crop institute
and they tried to do some of this work
uh looking at plant canopy that was um
uh photographed
uh and doing this on the go as well
so this is not a stop
you know
view and then it's a it's a real-time
system because
trying to get this to
a practical application is going to
require us to go at a certain speed
so we've got a knowledge base machine
system and application system
and this is again some the work by the
the group at uc davis
and basically this schematic shows you
that traveling in this direction
with this camera
image processing
computer and then connecting it to a
microcontroller
where okay we've identified the weeds
now can we spray those based on the
information that we collected uh going
through the field
and they've showed some success uh
especially where they can distinguish
tomato from nice shade and and pigweed
foliage so it's very right now it's very
rudimentary
but they're really making some
good nice progress in that way
so here's another um
you know looking at it again looking at
the shape
but also now adding the visual color
um looking at you know what are the
differences in the color of the plants
can we use that to to help us identify
it
and most recently
this group
has been awarded a grant to look at
doing kind of what they said here is is
is
modifying the color of that plant
to then allow them to differentiate
between the weeds and the plant
now what is this gonna what effect is
that gonna have on the production of the
plant
i don't know i that's yet to be seen
but but just you know changing this
color
um you know using
in this case a
a gene
that could be a way to help
kind of identify our desirable plants
versus weeds
so
true integrated weed management i think
we have an opportunity to actually you
know
pursue this now now that we have
technology
so we have sensors that can locate
individual weeds in the field
weeds can be identified based on their
characteristics or using a database
and then the decision support system
determines the best treatment
now the the part that is
is important is is is we're working at
the micro scale
and this is again a little bit of a
conceptual um
challenge
and it's not for a field that's just
loaded with weeds that's not the intent
it's a the intent is
where you where you've got some weed
management challenges and you can have a
robotic system go through identify where
the weeds are
if there's a known herbicide resistant
weed that computer can identify it and
apply a different treatment whether it's
a
you know a cutting treatment a burning
treatment but again it has to be at the
micro dose
level
so
advanced technology can account for
spatial temporal variability
and since we have all tools on board
they're available at any time and any
location in the field so you're you're
bringing integrated weed management to
the field
you're not waiting for different seasons
you're not rotating crops not that you
that you shouldn't be doing that but
those tools are there in real time so
conf conception to the field
these are some of the things um
this is a
swarm technology right now i don't know
if some of you've heard about that they
have these
individual kind of
spider looking robots that that kind of
move throughout the field and they have
a little area that they they manage
there's also some of these automated
machines that that they're looking at
where the weeds are and then they they
have actuators that that move um you
know within the row these are used in in
row crops
um
so that you know question are we still
at research grade i think we still are
there i know there's some startup
companies in california that are
actually uh you know working in this
area and they're actually making some
really
nice advances
but in general i think we're still kind
of looking at okay how do we make this
thing work and how do we do it
efficiently
so i'm just going to wrap up here with
just some final thoughts so i think
i think what was needed is kind of a
merging of attitudes not at emerging but
merging
and so what type of thinking do we need
to have
and i don't really think it's
conventional or sustainable i think it's
outside the box thinking i think just a
different approach and be thinking
broadly
not like our second photograph where
the young man was thinking are you
kidding me this is not a new frontier
so you know i think our mindset needs to
change about how do we view weeds
and so what do we need to be thinking
about weeds are plants
you know
some and some happen to be very
resilient so what can we learn from
those plants
are managing weeds when is it necessary
for complete control
as compared to when can we use
thresholds is there a time when we we
can allow weed or does it always have to
be you know annihilated
advanced technology is part of our
society how can we enhance our tools in
the integrated weed management toolbox
i think some of those things are up and
coming and there's either even other
things that i didn't mention
that are that are applicable
and we all know that weeds are
ubiquitous so what ecosystem services
are some weeds providing
and how can those services not the weeds
be exploited
you know so what can we
if if they're here we're dealing with
them
are there some ways that we can actually
incorporate them into our system in a
way that doesn't become detrimental to
our economics and our environment in
other ways
so that's all i have and i'd be happy to
answer any questions i think we have
maybe a few minutes or so
that's that's a very good question in
fact one of the things that i was i was
working on before i left unl was
training livestock to eat invasive
plants
so there's a person in colorado and
maybe some of you familiar but she has
trained
cows to eat weeds just google it and
you'll bring up her website
but in nebraska beef is like the number
one
commodity in in life's you know in
animal systems
so you've already got them out there
why can't you just train to eat the
things that you don't want
and she showed that you could do that
now i had some
there was it was not as simple as it
sounds but i i that's a very very good
you know idea whether it's
um genetically modifying them or just
training them
to eat uh these these plants that we
don't necessarily want
that's a very good question and it's a
good segue to my
presentation that i will be giving
uh in a couple weeks to the department
of natural resources on invasive plants
and ecology
so when i was at unl i had to basically
balance
agronomic weeds invasive plants
so i i kind of generalized for this
audience it's the agronomic side but the
invasive plants you know
are very much
obviously like you said they're less
intensively managed so how do we address
that i just had a conversation with um
with carrie the two carries before i got
in like where do we
say okay
you know am i am i making any difference
here am i making any progress on
especially at large scale and i think
that's where it really comes down to
um
defining what your goals are especially
when we talk to land managers you know
is is it a problem across your entire
landscape do you have patches do you
have satellite populations where you can
you know focus on those and i think
that's where we're we're really looking
at
removing those and and gets back to that
restoration study by those the folks
that you know in frontiers and
but that's that's a
maybe an equally as large or bigger
question
but it's a good point
all right well time's up so let's thank
steve once again
good job steve
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu